what's up y'all it's November which
could be deemed one of the most
attractive months of the year I'm
looking at you all you men with facial
hair keep it going I like it a
lumberjack man movember is a time where
a lot of men grow out their mustaches to
raise money and awareness for men's
mental health as well as other important
health issues I have a new digital
original series called televerses where
I just compete against people in games
because winning is fun
so to celebrate the month of facial hair
I'm going to play a fun game against the
creator of my hair Roberto Ramos and
your facial hair
of my beers
um or Robert Ramos if you're from Texas
no I say it Roberto Ramos Ramos yes
Ramos but I go by Robert sexy Spanish
Robert is on my Glam Squad he does my
hair and makes me look super awesome I
love him I love my Glam Squad y'all I
don't know what I do without them
foreign
this is amazing
like a decade decade ten and a half okay
I was gonna say it's gonna be that
that's when we work together first oh
but we don't know yet but we met with
that Midler
actually we go way back also interesting
oh my God
I I tried to get into the reservations
and and I couldn't they didn't have room
for me in for Kelly and Friends a week
and a half to two weeks later and he
literally within minutes
text me back and goes I got you in eight
people for
um I was like what so he can get your
reservations clearly I cannot clearly
today though we're going to play a game
where we try and Guess the Celebrity
from just their stash
I'll show it to you okay I have to get
it I have a full on like 70s have you
had like if you were gonna say seventies
each image has three levels of
difficulty starting at three points and
getting less as the image gets easier
okay first you hit the buzzer with the
correct celeb gets the point okay are
you ready I'm ready
by the end of this you're going to be
Kelly Clarkson begging for Mo points get
it moved remember movember let's play
the mo you know
here we go
[Music]
here we go
I want to say someone right now yeah I
mean someone no no no no no no no no no
I feel like it's Ted lasso
oh my God
we're not on a team no I know I just
realized that I know I was like I wanted
to say Ted lasso and then I was like is
it weird that I recognize just from Matt
to lasso but whatever I love Ted lasso
oh I know this mouth uh Tom Selleck no
it's not Tom Selleck um
I know because I could even see the oh
my God I know who this is I know who
this is and I'm not gonna I can't think
of it I even recognize the nose
already recognize like the crevice like
how do I study people that's weird that
I even knew that I love him I actually
love this shop in this movie
all right
[Music]
I want to say Steve Harvey no yeah they
didn't see Barbie yeah
do I have a chance at this point okay I
did want to make sure
[Music]
gonna need more yeah
[Music]
why do I know this face I I recognize
that face too I know even how the I
recognize that she like this
see I recognize that but
tell me something girl is it is it um is
it
Ryan Gosling no that is not right
something girl
[Music]
oh my God
we did not Zone in on that yeah oh my
God that's from shallow that's from
shallow in the shallow like that's um
[Music]
oh wow I wow just you know what we were
not
[Music]
Prince
oh look at Prince Right it kind of did
actually but I don't I feel like
hmm
Lionel Richie
[Music]
[Applause]
Lionel I never would have figured that
one out ever oh my God oh my God wait
she got four and I've got zero
oh I know that face uh
is it what's his face no oh my God
I know the women I don't know the man
that's why it's hilarious that I'm
playing this
um this Aussie MO is amazing with a
hammer oh no this is not who I thought
it was
oh my God
[Music]
[Music]
he said oh
my God I gotta be honest with you I
don't know that I really have seen him
with a mustache beautiful beard like a
fat Thor
he had like a whole beard I feel like
[Music]
this was like an old picture because
it's like black and white and like super
oh pretty Mercury
I gotta be honest with you yeah
I might be coming back look I'm from a
world where we had one TV in our house
so I never actually saw people unless
they were on an award show so I know
Queen music yeah I had no idea what
Freddie Mercury looked like until this
moment well you won one I know finally
whatever
[Music]
oh Albert Einstein
isn't it yes okay okay yes it is okay
oh Iron Man all right hello
wait Iron Man
um it is Robert Downey Jr remember
um
do I pay attention to people's lips and
mustaches a lot like this is crazy I
don't you don't
um well the score is amazing this is not
so good I got one right
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
make sure you subscribe to my channel
for more fun like this get it who wants
to miss this guys it's a good time thank
you for playing Robert thanks for having
me bye
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]